so we're waiting to see who will be in
joe biden's cabinet
and there have been a variety of
different names floated some have been
denied some have not been denied
it's very interesting to look at the way
that all goes and ultimately we're going
to know and we'll do a deep dive about
joe biden's cabinet
but as is often the case as a precursor
to selecting your cabinet
uh joe biden has selected his chief of
staff this is his first major staff pick
of course
the vice president kamala harris a very
important selection which was made some
time ago but
for post-election this is really good
news um
ronald klein is going to be joe biden's
chief of staff
it's just a great choice and everybody
from alexandria ocasio-cortez
to centrist democrats to democratic
consultants everybody says
this is a fantastic choice and i'm i'm
going to tell you a little bit about
ronald clayne
but when the bar is not not that claine
isn't a good choice no matter what
but when the bar is so low already
because of donald
trump ronald klein is an adult who
is not only intelligent but he's
organized and he
gets things done that's already going to
be much better than the people that
donald trump has had
as chiefs of staff ronald klein also
happened to be barack obama's ebola czar
during the obama biden administration
and if we want to talk about signals
when joe biden selects ronald clayne
it's a signal that he rejects the chaos
of the trump administration he rejects
the idea of these
wild loose cannon unhinged staffers in a
lot of different positions
ron i'm going to be very up front ronald
klein is going to be a boring chief of
staff
he's going to be a a sensible sober
chief of staff you're not likely to hear
a lot from ronald klein
in terms of cartoonish incidents and
scandals
and fiascos and if you're dealing with a
pandemic as joe biden is going to be
and unfortunately because donald trump
is just done with coronavirus
a very serious pandemic on january 20th
ronald klein is also particularly
qualified because he has experience
dealing with medical outbreaks already
he's a lawyer with a solid legal mind
he has a relatively progressive lien in
terms of what you would expect
for a president like joe biden and he
has the experience that is required at
exactly this time and again
widespread praise uh aoc tweeting quote
good news and an encouraging choice
anti-trump republican steve schmidt
who's not our friend but but the the
point is
everybody recognizes ronald klein is a
good choice uh steve schmidt
tweeting looks like the office of chief
of staff
has just been upgraded by 100 gazillion
percent
with the appointment of ronald clayne
squad member
congresswoman ayanna presley tweeting
quote
having a dedicated humble hard-working
team around you
is everything congratulations ronald
klein encouraged to see you step into
this role
and look forward to working together
senator elizabeth warren
tweeting ronald klein is a superb choice
for chief of staff
he understands the magnitude of the
health and economic crisis
and he has the experience to lead this
next administration
through it ron has earned trust all
across the entire democratic party i
think you get it
in washington you rarely see such
unified and nearly unanimous reaction to
any choice for any position
ever no matter how qualified the person
is he was on the ball
uh ronald klein was in terms of
coronavirus he wrote back in january
uh nearly 11 months ago a piece in the
atlantic where he said
or the piece was called coronavirus is
coming and trump isn't ready and he
explained
the ways in which donald trump was not
ready so eventually we're going to be
doing a deep dive
on joe biden's cabinet as it comes
together expecting
some names around thanksgiving time but
for now
the person who will be helping biden
choose the cabinet is as close to a
perfect selection
as there could be and contrast it with
donald trump's
latest chief of staff mark meadows who
has been running around trump rallies
with no mask high-fiving people
uh mark meadows caught coronavirus mark
meadows
continued to insist that donald trump
would win even though donald trump
lost and said weeks ago we are not going
to control
the pandemic in what was arguably the
most
defeatist statement we've heard from any
administration official about the
pandemic since the start so
change is very much in the air i don't
expect to agree with every cabinet
choice joe biden makes but
so far this is exactly what you would
want to see now let me say one other
thing
there have been i've been getting a lot
of emails from from people linking me to
articles some articles saying
warren and bernie are being considered
for cabinet positions
and other articles saying warren and
bernie are being frozen out of
consideration for cabinet positions
uh with so many rumors floating around
and so many cabinet positions and so
much else to talk about
i don't think there's much value in me
commenting
on speculation about biden's cabinet
when biden chooses his cabinet we will
do a deep dive we will analyze
every single cabinet member some of you
will find it boring some of you will
find it valuable
i think it's very important and we're
going to do that to sort of
set up our understanding of the biden
administration as it comes in
one of the things i think is important
to think about
is that when you select democratic
senators to your cabinet
their senate seats open different states
have different rules
about who and how gets to decide on
their replacement
here in massachusetts we have a
republican governor
currently and as at least as an interim
replacement
to elizabeth warren until there's a
special election
that may mean a republican senator uh
replaces elizabeth warren in vermont i
actually don't know off hand exactly
how it goes but while i obviously
believe that elizabeth warren and bernie
sanders
would be fantastic cabinet selections
bernie could be secretary of labor
there's other positions he could do
elizabeth warren could be
secretary of education treasury
secretary
you know you could make an argument for
either of them as secretary of commerce
there's no doubt that these are
qualified people i do
and i don't pretend to have an answer to
this question it is it's not rhetorical
it's a real question
are we better served by keeping bernie
and warren
the two most progressive members of the
senate right now
in the senate i think that that's a
completely legitimate question to be
asking
and given that you could pick people
that are arguably as good or almost as
good as them
for cabinet positions although maybe
they would be less recognizable in terms
of name recognition
do we gain more by keeping them in the
senate i think
that almost certainly if warren and
bernie leave the senate to be in biden's
cabinet
it's a guarantee that the senate moves
to the right
when you take the two most liberal
members of the senate
and you replace them with people that
are arguably and almost certainly
less liberal the average political
orientation of the senate moves a little
bit to the right and i think that that's
a perfectly
legitimate and important thing to be
talking about and we will discuss it
if democratic senators do make it into
biden's cabinet we will talk about it
if they don't and there are complaints
where is bernie where is warren
we will also talk about it a completely
um
fundamental understanding of the reality
of what happens when you take
a democratic senator out uh what happens
to that seat
in the immediate and also in the medium
to long term when there is a special
election
we'll have more about ronald klein and
biden's cabinet on our instagram page
follow us there at davidpakmanshow and
listen
if you're already on instagram follow me
at david.pakman as well